[Music]
the evolutionary tango of animal
genitalia
can you guess what you're looking at if
you answered duck vagina you'd be right
although the birds outward appearance
may not strike you as especially odd it
uses this strange intricate
corkscrew-shaped contraption to
reproduce we see similarly unbelievable
genitalia in insects mammals reptiles
fish spiders and even snails apparently
no organs evolved faster and into more
variable shapes than those involved in
procreation superficially it makes sense
because evolution works for reproduction
if an animal leaves more offspring his
genes will spread and since genitalia
and animals tools for reproduction any
improvement there will have immediate
effect and yet what's the point of
having such decorative nether regions
after all the function of genitalia
seems simple a penis deposits a bit of
sperm and a vagina receives it and
delivers it to the egg a pipette like
thingy on the mail and a funnel like
gizmo on the female should do just fine
for any home and yet that's not what we
see the penis of a chicken free for
example looks nothing like a pipette
more like an exploded grandfather clock
and the vagina of a feather wing beetle
resembles something you'd find in a dr.
Seuss book throughout the animal kingdom
genitalia of very complex things much
more complicated than seems necessary
for what they're meant to do that's
because genitalia do more than just
deposit and receive sperm many male
animals also use the penis as a
courtship device like crane flies in
some South American species males have a
tiny washboard and scraper on their
penis which produces a song that
reverberates throughout the female's
body when they mate it's thought that if
female crane flies enjoy this unusual
serenade they'll allow the male to
father
offspring this way the genes of the most
musical penises spread leading to rapid
evolution of insects phalluses similarly
some beetles have two little drumsticks
on either side of the penis during
mating they'll rub slap or tap the
female with these and some hoofed
mammals
like Rams of bulls use a whip like
extension on the penises left side to
trait a sensation during mating but how
can a female really choose between males
if you can only assess them after mating
this is where the power of female
adaptation comes into play in fact
insemination is different to conception
and the female genitalia exploit this
distinction for instance in some dung
flies the vagina contains pockets for
separating sperm from different males
depending on how appealing they were
males using their penises for courtship
and females controlling their own sperm
management are two reasons why genitalia
evolved into such complex shapes but
there are others because genitalia are
also where a sexual conflict is played
out a female's interests are best served
if she fertilizes her eggs with the
sperm of the best fathers and creates
genetic variability amongst her
offspring from male on the other hand
this is bad news for him it will be best
if a female used his sperm to fertilize
all of her eggs so we see cycles of
adaptation in an evolutionary arms race
to retain control black widow spiders
have a disposable penis tip that breaks
off inside the vagina blocking the
attempts of his rivals and bedbug males
bypass a female's genitalia altogether
using a syringe like penis to inject
sperm cells directly
belly not to be outdone females have
evolved their own countermeasures in
some bedbug species the females have
evolved an entirely new set of genitalia
on their right hand flanks where the
males usually pierce them that allows
them to maintain the power to filter out
unwanted sperm with their genitalia and
duck vaginas are shaped like a clockwise
spiral so that when the male inflates
his long counter clockwise coiled penis
into her and she disapproves all she
needs to do is flex her vaginal muscles
and the penis just flops out so
genitalia differs so much not just to
fascinate us but because in every
species they're the result of a furious
evolutionary tangle of sex that has been
going on for millions of years
and will continue for millions of years
to come
[Music]
you